ni más ni menos que el doble de los
50.000 casos oficiales las autoridades
de salud francesa hacen sonar las
alarmas frente a lo que creen que podría
ser la cifra real de contagios diaria
estamos en una situación muy difícil o
incluso crítica probablemente hay más de
50.000 casos cada día estimamos en el
consejo científico que estamos más bien
en alrededor de 100.000 casos diarios el
doble del número registrado de presos en
medio de la segunda ola que golpea a
europa francia está en el ojo del
huracán el país está examinando
actualmente la posibilidad de endurecer
las medidas de bloqueo para frenar el
resurgimiento del cob y 19 habiendo ya
impuesto toques de queda nocturnos en
las principales ciudades y en 38
departamentos algunos médicos creen que
francia ha perdido el control del virus
yo creo que ya no tenemos elección el
virus está tan presente a nuestro
alrededor que hoy en día ya no tenemos
elección tenemos que volver a
implementar un confinamiento un poco
como lo que han hecho los irlandeses
reales es para reiniciar el temporizador
y detener la saturación de los sistemas
hospitalarios al hospital y sin temor y
reanimación
con más de 1.100.000 infecciones
diagnosticadas francia ya super
argentina y españa al registrar el
quinto número de casos más elevado del
mundo el total de muertes se acerca por
su parte a las 35.000 víctimas